it's my privilege to introduce John
steel Gordon John steel Gordon was born
in New York City and educated at the
Millbrook school and Vanderbilt
University graduating with a BA in
history in 1966 after college he worked
as a production editor for Harper & row
now HarperCollins for six years before
leaving to travel driving a Land Rover
from New York to Tierra del Fuego a
nine-month journey of 39,000 miles this
resulted in his first book over landing
and altogether he has driven through 47
countries on five continents
he worked in politics and has been a
full-time writer for the last 25 years
and is the author of numerous books his
latest book an empire of wealth the epic
history of American economic power
published in 2004 is a history of the
American economy
mr. Gordon specializes in business
financial and engineering history and is
a sought-after analyst on television and
radio broadcasts please welcome John
steel Gordon
thank you very much it's true I used to
do a lot of traveling by car all over
the place nowadays I prefer business
class and four-star hotel size it's
great to be back at a Hillsdale College
event I am also a recidivist this is my
third time and actually I was on
Hillsdale cruise a couple of years ago
which I highly recommend giving lectures
while the boat is moving at fifteen not
um I'm also very glad to be here in San
Diego rather than and certainly Chile
and probably gray and dank Hillsdale in
southern Michigan I'm here tonight to
talk about entrepreneurship and American
history
now the word entrepreneur one who
undertakes manages and crucially assumes
the risk of a new enterprise is an
interesting one it comes from the French
surprisingly France whatever it's
multiple and glorious contributions to
world civilization maybe is hardly known
for its entrepreneurial spirit indeed
and historically the most dearest
society in Europe is known for the exact
opposite the word literally means
Undertaker and in in French often means
exactly as somebody who handles funerals
it can also mean contractor or even a
furniture mover what it doesn't mean is
a risk taker and Enterprise Builder as
it does in English now the word
entrepreneur was only borrowed into
English recently in the mid nineteenth
century perhaps the Golden Age of the
entrepreneur at that time the number of
new economic niches to use a biological
term was exploding while the hand of
government was at its lightest in
history but the activity of course is
far older in the first century BC the
Roman Marcus Licinius Crassus organized
what today would be called a fire
company he would rush to the site of a
burning building and if the owner and
sometimes his threatened neighbors
agreed
sell cheaply he would put out the fire
um if not he let it burn he became one
of the richest men in Rome now how far
back does entrepreneurship go in
American history when the answer is the
very beginning this country was founded
quite literally by entrepreneurs in 1607
the Virginia company sent three ships
across the Atlantic and unloaded 109
passengers at what became Jamestown
Virginia they were embarked on a new
business enterprise that they hoped
would be profitable American plantations
now the Virginia Company was a joint
stock company a relatively new invention
that allowed people to invest in
enterprises without running the risk of
losing everything if the business did
not succeed by limiting liability
corporations greatly increase the number
of people who could dare to become
entrepreneurs by pooling their resources
with others while avoiding the
possibility of ruin thus the corporation
is one of the great inventions of the
Renaissance right up there with printing
double-entry bookkeeping and the
full-rigged ship also allowing
corporation as a matter of law rather
than requiring an act of the executive
as in Britain or the legislature in the
United States began as early in this
country as 1811 when new york state
passed a general incorporation law for
certain businesses including linen
manufacturers and for some reason the
makers of anchors I suspect it was an
anchor maker who had good relations in
Albany this freed incorporation from
politics and the number of corporations
exploded there but only seven companies
incorporated in British North America
but the state of Pennsylvania alone
incorporated more than two thousand
between 1800 and 1860 unfortunately for
the stockholders of the Virginia company
the business of American plantations was
a very new one and that meant it had a
steep learning curve
a curve that would be encountered again
and again as the American economy
developed new industries it was a curve
all entrepreneurs had to climb to be
successful
the Virginia company did not climb that
curve quickly enough and made just about
every mistake it was possible for them
to make at first they tried to run
Jamestown as a company town with the
settlers in effect employees but many of
the settlers were second sons of the
gentry and aristocracy they hope to make
a quick buck and then beat it back to
England they were disinclined to do hard
physical labor they searched for gold of
which Virginia has none and instead of
planting crops which is why many of them
starve to death in the first winter and
one was executed for having eaten his
wife they they even shipped home a
shipload of iron pyrites often called
fool's gold hoping it was the real stuff
one can only imagine the reaction of the
investors back in England when that
cargo was offloaded the following year
the Virginia company sent over glass
makers from Poland and Bavaria glass was
in sharply increased demand in England
but was increasingly expensive as glass
making requires prodigious quantities of
fuel and England's forests were being
rapidly depleted the company hoped that
Tidewater Virginia is abundant sand and
wood could support a profitable glass
making industry within a year however
the project was in ruins and the glass
makers returned to Europe where they
could make a far better living in far
more comfortable circumstances the new
colony struggled desperately to survive
exporting a few furs some timber
sassafras and silk grass from which mats
were woven at one point Jamestown was
very nearly abandoned only when John
Rolfe introduced West Indian tobacco in
1619 did Virginia find an export that
had a market in Europe indeed a market
that grew explosively in the following
decades and made Virginia rich
by that time of course it was far too
late for the Virginia Company which went
broke the colony became a royal
possession in 1623 now it has not been
nearly well enough noted that the
American colonies while many ended up in
royal hands were not founded by the
English state several such as
Massachusetts Bay Plymouth and Virginia
were founded by profit seeking
corporations others such as Pennsylvania
and Maryland were founded by proprietors
now to be sure many of these enterprises
had non entrepreneurial motives such as
providing a refuge for religious
dissenters John Winthrop one of the
Puritans to establish a shining city on
a hill
William Penn thought of Pennsylvania as
a holy experiment where Quakers could
live in peace but Plymouth Colony
Massachusetts Bay and Pennsylvania were
also all expected to show a profit as
William Penn explained though I desire
to extend religious freedom yet I want
some recompense from my troubles when
the pilgrims sent back sent the
Mayflower back to England and ballast
they got a furious letter from the
investors in England demanding to know
why they had not sent back a cargo of
goods to be sold now New York of course
was founded by the Dutch not the
Englishmen and profit was the sole
reason for settling in Manhattan the
colony made a profit for the Dutch West
India Company the very first year
indeed so bent on money-making were the
Dutch that they did not even get around
to building a church for 17 years
worshipping instead in the fort when
they finally did build a church they
named it for Saint Nicholas and Santa
Claus has been the patron saint in New
York ever since
indeed the modern Santa Claus is in fact
a New York invention now this is no
small reason why American religious
toleration began in New York when the
autocratic Peter Stuyvesant tried to
expel the Jews and the Quakers from
makalah
they wrote the West India Company in
Amsterdam the letter is known as the
flushing remonstrance and the company
wrote Stevenson telling him in no
uncertain terms to mind his own damn
business so the Jews and the Quakers
could mine theirs and contribute to the
colony's success even after the British
took the colony in 1664 the Dutch
live-and-let-live spirit and devotion to
commerce remained harking back to the
early sources of its economic success
the fur trade the city's seal remains to
this day a beaver surrounded by wampum
even today that little hustle e bustle e
let's make a deal Dutch village lies at
the heart of the vast metropolis the
world's most important and powerful city
and making money is still New York's
greatest love I expect that the spirit
will survive the new mayor even though
he likes to honeymoon with tyrants even
in the theocracy that was early New
England the entrepreneurial spirit
burned bright
unlike the colonies on the Chesapeake
there was no cash crop that could be
grown in New England's stony soil and
short growing season perhaps the closest
thing to a cash crop was that singular
Beast the Atlantic cod pulled from the
great fishing waters off New England and
prodigious numbers it was salted and
dried and shipped to Europe to provide
cheap protein for the masses even today
there is a carving of a codfish hanging
in the Massachusetts State House to
remind people of the early sources of
their success now Puritans thought that
worldly success was a sign of God's
grace and many Puritan merchants and
Puritanism was essentially a middle
class movement wrote at the top of their
Ledger's in the name of God and prophet
perhaps because New England lacked a
cash crop such as tobacco rice or sugar
its economy quickly became much more
diverse than those in the southern and
West Indian colonies shipping and
shipbuilding lumber fishing slaving and
rum distilling
became mainstays of the New England
economy and produced its earliest
fortunes Massachusetts Bay even
established a college as early as 1637
only seven years after the colony was
founded although to be sure at first its
only purpose was to train new Puritan
ministers Harvard has widened its
academic scope a bit since then the
printing press at Harvard began the
American publishing industry when it
produced the first book ever printed in
America in 1640 the bay psalm book by
the way if you'd like a copy be sure to
be at sotheby's on november 26 when one
will be auctioned however don't forget
to bring your checkbook as it's expected
to go for fifteen to thirty million
dollars the highest price ever paid for
a book at auction far more central to
the evolving new england economy however
was iron a commodity that had been by
then indispensable for three thousand
years iron was needed for pots
plowshares horseshoes weapons farm
implements nails shipbuilding and a
myriad of other items and industries and
it had all had to be imported at vast
expense from the iron foundries in
england a 2-month upwind voyage from
Boston John Winthrop the younger son of
the man who coined the phrase a city on
a hill saw opportunity and a born
entrepreneur he seized it now there was
plenty of iron ore available but to make
iron Winthrop needed something America
did not then have at all capital he
sailed to England of 1641 to get it why
one might well wondered when any
capitalist be so foolhardy has to invest
a major industrial enterprise located in
the wilderness 3,000 miles away the
answer lay in something that America did
have an indescribable abundance and as
already mentioned was increasing short
supply in England wood charcoal was as
indispensable to iron smelting as or but
England's forests are being rapidly cut
down America however had well over 1
million square miles of forest
so Winthrop was able to argue that
combining America's cheap raw materials
with England's capital would produce a
product that could be sold at a profit
not only in Massachusetts but in England
as well by all accounts he was a most
engaging and persuasive man he was also
a very learned at one he would become
the first American to be named a fellow
of the Royal Society I believe the
second was that great scientist writer
diplomat and entrepreneur Benjamin
Franklin certainly Winthrop was able to
persuade many people in England to
invest indeed they put up no less than
fifteen thousand pounds to get a sense
of how much money that's some
represented in Massachusetts in the
1640s considered that the highest annual
salary in the entire colony in 1648 was
the ninety pounds
paid to a clergyman the Reverend
Zechariah Sims of Charlestown tells you
a lot about how different early
Massachusetts was from modern America
that the highest-paid salary in the
place was a to a clergyman now Winthrop
called his new company the company of
Undertaker's note the word the literal
translation of entrepreneur now the
government in Massachusetts granted them
a monopoly on iron production for
twenty-one years an exemption from
taxation and the right to export iron
once local demand was met obviously cozy
relations between government and
industry is not holding a 20th century
phenomenon now the Saugus ironworks as
it was known was a financial failure as
so many first attempts are but it is now
a National Historic Site and well it
should be for was the start of a great
American industry by the end of the
colonial era the colonies were producing
one seventh of the world's pig iron a
little more than a hundred years further
on we were producing more iron and steel
than Britain and Germany combined and
doing it so efficiently that we were
exporting iron and steel to both those
countries at that time the iron and
steel industry in this
she was dominated by Andrew Carnegie who
hadn't arrived from Scotland as a as a
child you know with absolutely without
any money whatsoever in 1901 he sold out
to JP Morgan who congratulated Carnegie
on becoming the richest man in the world
the Saugus ironworks also saw the
beginning of one of the handmaidens of
American entrepreneurial success the
American invention the first patent
awarded to an American resident was
given to Joseph Jenks in 1646 for a
device that improved the manufacture of
edged tools such as sickles it was the
beginning of the Yankee ingenuity that
has characterized the American economy
for the last 350 years from the first
machine tool to bifocal glasses the
cotton gin automated flour mills
high-pressure steam engines
interchangeable parts the McCormick
Reaper the oil industry the airplane
coca-cola the affordable automobile the
digital computer and Twitter now if
you'd like an example of how great a
synergistic effect entrepreneurship and
Yankee ingenuity have had on American
economy consider this when Twitter went
public last week the stock offering
produced no fewer than 1,600 newly
minted millionaires now the role that
immigration has played in the success of
American entrepreneurship cannot be
overstated as we've seen with Andrew
Carnegie indeed you cannot understand
the United States without understanding
one vital fact about it the United
States is a nation of immigrants
everyone living today in the United
States either came himself or has
ancestors who came although to be sure
some came and remote antiquity across
the Bering Strait this fact explains a
lot the early 17th century was a time of
great troubles in Britain the economy
was struggling and the politics were
deteriorating as the country lurched
toward civil war many people in effect
said oh dear oh dear things are terrible
somebody has got to do something
but others didn't sit around bemoaning
their troubles instead they did
something themselves they took an
enormous risk they said goodbye to
everyone and everything they had ever
known and came to a strange land in
search of a better life to get an idea
of how much of a risk they were taking
consider that fully 25 percent of the
people who emigrated to Virginia in the
early years did not survive their first
year if they did they were said to have
been seasoned half of the passengers on
the Mayflower did not survive that first
terrible winter so it took a lot of guts
and a lot of gumption and both our
inheritable qualities and that has had
enormous consequences the French and the
Spanish government's far more
authoritarian than the British and with
a direct interest in running their
colonies from the very beginning we're
very careful about who was permitted to
emigrate to those colonies they wanted
no troublemakers no dissidents and
especially no religious heretics the
British government on the other hand
couldn't have cared less who went to the
colonies indeed they were only too glad
to get rid of their troublemakers by
sending them there the result was a
remarkably feisty mix of people and
they're remarkably entrepreneurial
gene-pool some just marched to the beat
of a distant drummer some arrived one
jump ahead of the sheriff and some to be
sure one jumped behind the sheriff being
transported as criminals but the bulk
aim of their own free will and have been
coming ever since in hopes of finding a
better and richer life what was true in
the seventeenth century when people
cross the Atlantic and small sailing
ships it took two months to reach
America was equally true if somewhat
less hazardous in the early 20th century
when immigrants arrived at Ellis Island
in steerage it is true today when
immigrants arrived by bus and by jet and
not infrequently by night and on foot
many people sold themselves into
temporary slavery called indentured
servitude in order to get here but they
were willing to do so now why well Sir
Henry more royal governor of New York
and 1767 explains it quote as soon as
the time stipulated in their indentures
is expired they immediately quit their
masters and get a small tract of land in
settling which for the first three or
four years they lead miserable lives in
the most abject poverty but all is
patiently borne and submitted to with
the greatest cheerfulness the
satisfaction of being land holders
smooth every difficulty they had become
men of property now Americans were and
are strivers with a deep yearning to
better their lot and that of their
children that has often manifested
itself in entrepreneurial activity so if
the United States is famous for its get
up and go it is because we Americans all
have ancestors who got up and came in
search of Economic Opportunity even
those who arrived as slaves and thus had
no choice about it survives an ordeal
that is utterly beyond modern
imagination and past that incredible
strength down to their descendants by
the time the 13 colonies declared
independence they were after only 169
years the richest place on earth per
capita no less than 40% of the British
Merchant Marine by far the world's
largest was engaged in trade with the
North American colonies no wonder the
British fought so hard to suppress the
rebellion it might be noted that while
statistics in the late 18th century can
be very scarce the very word statistics
wouldn't be coined until the early 19th
century there is one powerful statistic
indicating just how better off Americans
were than their British close cousins
soldiers in the Continental Army
averaged a full two inches taller than
those in the British regiments fighting
in America our timing and declaring
independence could not have been better
Adam Smith's The Wealth of Nations was
published
very same year as Independence was
declared being very young we did not
have the burden of hundreds of years of
economic cronyism there was no
aristocracy no gills no ancient
monopolies or hereditary tariffs as they
were in continental Europe and to a
lesser extent in Britain although they
didn't have hereditary tariffs there and
therefore Karl Marx was wrong as he
usually was when he wrote quote men make
their own history but they do not make
it as they please they do not make it
under circumstances chosen by themselves
but under circumstances directly
encountered and transmitted from the
past but we have less passed than any
other country and therefore we could
make our own history creating the most
smithing an economy in the Western world
to be sure the United States did not
produce a purely Smithian economy people
and government will always try to help
those who are powerful at the expense of
those who might become so what is can
always wield influence that what might
be cannot match but the United States
has consistently come closer to the
Smithee and ideal over a longer period
of time than any other major nation
nothing encourages entrepreneurial
activity more than the freedom to take
risk and in the early days there were
almost no rules
now take a man probably most of you have
never heard of Frederic Tudor in 1806 he
had an idea to sell ice he wanted to get
it where it was cheap New England and
sell it where it was precious the
southern states and the West Indies this
was considered absolutely lunatic he was
laughed at the problem of course was how
to get it from here to there and still
have it be ice not water the answer lay
in a waste product sawdust which the
lumber mills were more than happy to
have him cart away for free sawdust is
an excellent insulator so Tudor took two
chief
things and made them valuable simply by
changing their location by 1820 he was
shipping 2000 tons of ice a year out of
New England they got wet as far as
Calcutta and if you've ever been in
Calcutta you surely know that ice must
have been a wonderful thing to see by
the 1850s ice was one of the largest of
all American exports and he was selling
it for like 25 cents a pound so he's
making like a million dollars a year on
ice and of course then along came
refrigeration and that was the end of
the American ice trade now the second
great spurt entrepreneurship is the
freedom to fail no country in the world
has been as consistently tolerant of
economic failure as the United States
while bankruptcy in Europe has always
been regarded as a moral as well as a
financial failure that has not been the
case here possibly that is because we
are all descendants of people who sought
a second chance by coming here now there
were to be sure debtors prisons in
colonial and early Republican America
and some very distinguished people spent
time in them including James Wilson
while he was sitting as one of the first
associate justices of the Supreme Court
as far as I know he's the only Supreme
Court justice to have experienced the
inside of the jail but debtors prisons a
remarkably counterproductive institution
after all how do you pay off your debts
while you're cooling your heels in jail
was abandoned in the United States
earlier than elsewhere the federal
government ended the practice under
federal law in 1833 and most states had
followed suit by 1850 Great Britain
wouldn't abolish debtors prisons until
1869 the Constitution provided for
bankruptcy to be a federal
responsibility in order to prevent
people abscond into another state to
escape their debts but of course the
frontier was a nearly perfect place to
lose one's identity and try again
millions did exactly that as a result of
this freedom to fail without suffering
social of program many entrepreneurs
were able on their second or third or
fourth try to strike it rich consider
Henry Flagler who began his business
career in the wholesale commodity
business and prospered so well that he
was making an income of about fifty
thousand dollars a year by the time of
the civil war that was a very
comfortable income indeed at that time
the civil war drove the price of salt
through the roof and Flagler invested
heavily in a salt company in Michigan
when the war ended however the price of
salt collapsed as did the business
Flagler who had risen from the son of an
itinerant preacher to the one-percent
was broke he had to borrow money from
his father-in-law at 10% interest no
less in order to feed and house his
family only five years later Flagler was
a founding partner of Standard Oil with
one-sixth the ownership of that company
later after running Standard Oil had
become a matter of management not
entrepreneurship Flagler would use his
Standard Oil millions to create the
modern state of Florida turning it from
a semi tropical wilderness to a tourist
mecca an agricultural powerhouse no
individuals have a greater effect upon a
single state than Florida than Flagler
had upon Florida with the possible
exception of Brigham Young and Utah or
consider one of my favorite
nineteenth-century entrepreneurs Isaac
Merritt's singer he was on his own by
the time he was 12 and only basically
literate a character straight out of
Dickens at 19 he obtained an
apprenticeship in a met and a machine
shop and soon demonstrated a marked
talent for mechanics
unfortunately for singer he wanted to be
an actor a profession for which he had
at best a pedestrian talent but that is
a bug that can be very hard to shake New
Yorkers and Los Angelenos are all
familiar with being waited on in
restaurants by people in their 30s and
even their
forty's still hoping to break through
and show business singer tinkered on the
side all the while be getting an amazing
number of children by both wives and
mistresses he invented a rock drill
there was a great improvement over
earlier means of drilling but he was so
desperate for money that he sold the
patent for a mere $2,000 as a sum that
soon vanished in providing for his
family or more accurately families only
when he finally gave up acting in middle
age did he turn his attention full-time
to mechanics and soon invented a new
kind of sewing machine it had one great
advantage over previous machines such as
the one patented by Elias how singers
machine actually worked once the patent
situation was settled it was the first
use of what is now a standard model for
dealing with complex inventions in which
many people contribute pieces the patent
pool he made a vast fortune as a sewing
machine revolutionized and
industrialized the clothing industry
it's not hard to see why a shirt that
took a seamstress 14 hours to sew by
hand could now be produced in an hour
and a half many clothing workers feared
for their livelihoods but of course the
effect of the sewing machine
was to enlarge their business not
destroy it
as the price of ready-made clothes
dropped the increasing market for them
made up for the lower prices many times
over this is one of the fundamental
means by which capitalism has made the
world a richer place for everyone
because it is a low tech and not at all
capital intensive business clothing
manufacturer has long been the first
rung of the ladder for both individuals
and for countries now I took inventory
as I was getting dressed this evening
and I'm presently wearing clothes that
were manufactured in no fewer than seven
different underdeveloped countries
Vietnam Indonesia China Mexico
Bangladesh El Salvador and Sri Lanka the
buttons however on my blazer were made
in the USA
when singer died in 1975 the former
down-and-out actor left in a state of
about 13 million dollars that would have
put him on the Forbes 400 list have
there been such a thing at the time but
it was dissipated in a single generation
as the New York Herald delighted to be
able to report such tittle-tattle wrote
quote under the terms of his will some
twenty or more of his offspring by
diverse and sundry mothers are entitled
to an average of about two hundred
thousand each
by the time of Isaac's singer's death
the American economy was undergoing
profound changes as giant corporations
with tens of thousands of employees and
thousands of stockholders emerged
lagging far behind where the rules
needed for such an economy to operate
for the benefit of all many thought like
plutocracy threatened and plutocracy
threatens a country's entrepreneurial
spirit quite as much as an overbearing
government especially if the plutocrats
and politicians get together as they are
want to do if their mutual if short-term
self-interest
there is this is of course a classic
example of crony capitalism Standard Oil
was able to muscle many small operators
into selling out by threatening ruin if
they did not standards relationship with
the railroads allow them to ship much
more cheaply than the smaller refiners
and often received an under-the-table
kickback on the oil that the small
operators did ship standard would always
offer what it regarded as the fair price
but it was take it or leave it and
leaving it was usually not an option
this is not altogether dissimilar to the
racket run by Marcus Licinius Crassus in
ancient Rome the lack of rules sometimes
left the theft of the stockholders
investment in all but name in earlier
times an organization's managers were
almost always owners as well as and thus
had an identity of interests with all
the owners but as capital requirements
rose managers very often came to be at
best small shareholders
so the self-interests of management and
shareholders diverged the Union Pacific
Railroad for instance was chartered by
the federal government to build part of
a transcontinental Highway railroad I'm
sorry the newly installed management
organized a construction company owned
by themselves
gave it a fancy French name credi Moby
Lang and hired themselves to build the
railroad guess what they overcharged to
make sure Congress didn't make any
trouble
they cut key members in on the deal
including the vice president allowing
them to pay for credi mobil a stock
using the enormous quarterly dividends
that had been that they were often 100
percent of par value that they were paid
the result was a bankrupt railroad that
had been shamili constructed managers
also did not have to make regular
reports to their stockholders in most
cases and even when they did they could
keep the books as they pleased and they
certainly did Wall Street with a
powerful interest in knowing the truth
about the corporations whose securities
were traded and underwritten there began
imposing regular accounting rules and
quarterly audited reports the result was
a far more honest capital market where
entrepreneurs could come in search of
financing with a certainty that they
would be treated fairly and have their
risk-taking properly rewarded if the
idea was a success
this was a huge spur to entrepreneurship
government too sought to police the
marketplace but with far less success in
Wall Street it had railroads were
brought under the federal regulatory
regime that quickly evolved into a
cartel called the Interstate Commerce
Commission trucking came under its
control in the 1930s and airlines were
regulated by their own cartel the Civil
Aeronautics Board now cartels and
monopolies of course prevent competition
and thus entrepreneurship that in turn
prevents the creative destruction that
is so vital to capitalism
after the ICC and CA B lost their rate
setting and route allocating powers in
the late 1970s transportation costs
action cost dropped from 15% of GDP to
only 10% allowing lower prices for
almost all goods at the same time
innovation flourished old legacy
airlines like Pan Am and TWA and Eastern
and Brenner unable to compete in the new
environment disappeared new airlines
with new strategies such as Southwest
and JetBlue emerged entrepreneurship
returned to transportation from where it
had long been absent with the birth of
the digital age there has been a new
golden age of entrepreneurship in this
country and to a lesser extent all over
the world thousands of new niches have
become available to exploit many of them
being able to be exploited extremely
cheaply the result has been the greatest
inflorescence of fortune making and
fortune making usually implies
entrepreneurship in human history 1982
it took 82 million dollars to have a
place on the Forbes list today it takes
well over a billion dollars and just
look at the fours 400 list and see how
many of these fortunes date to just the
last 30 years
many of these fortune makers are young
Mark Zuckerberg well up on the Forbes
400 list thanks to Facebook is still
under 30 just recently an
australian-born programmer named Nick
D'Alessio sold an app he had designed to
Yahoo for 30 million dollars mr.
D'Alessio turned 18 on the 1st of this
month the opportunity is for people with
ideas and a willingness to take risks
are limitless today there is plenty of
capital available to bring those ideas
to life and mechanisms to bring ideas
and capital together are much more
robust than they were in the
not-too-distant past so the future of
entrepreneurship in this most
entrepreneurial of countries remains
very bright the only fear is that an
overbearing government bent on managing
the American economy supposedly for the
good of all but actually for the benefit
of the bureaucracy and politicians who
will begin to strangle the goose that
has laid so many golden eggs
that is always a danger for government
is just a subject to the law of
self-interest as the marketplace is
unfortunately the process of creative
destruction is far less vigorous in
government which is a monopoly by its
nature on the other hand government
regularly displays an incompetence so
extraordinary that reform becomes
possible I think we are witnessing such
a display right now
with the launch of Obamacare which makes
the maiden voyage of the Titanic look
like a triumph
they Obamacare which seeks to raid 1/6
of the American economy of even a
vestige of entrepreneurship and turn it
over to the public sector but I'm always
an optimist so I think good things will
come out of this debacle with Obamacare
I certainly hope so thank you very much
I'm happy to answer any questions do we
have
yes she's coming up
first thank you for a very inspiring
talk I write for parents and so does our
speaker and so you can read some of this
wonderful essays in Barron's hope you're
going to continue to to write for Berens
I John I certainly hope so I first I
want I want to correct you on one point
they've even argued with you on another
point the word entrepreneur appears in
the book that was published in 1755 by
Richard Conte on it's written in French
Conte I by the way was originally Irish
but he wrote in French and he explains
that it's about risk-taking
and indeed John Baptist say wrote about
entrepreneurship as well he's vows for
say his law also about risk-taking
there's actually a rich French tradition
having to do with entrepreneurship and
market oriented economics Bastiat of
course is another great name these three
people are not very well known in France
you're absolutely right about that but
indeed it's a girl it's glorious that
actually this term did come from France
and they did mean risk-taker and they
didn't mean the the very thing that
you've been talking about well that's
not what it means in French today Jimmy
yes that's true but respect the
tradition of Kantian John Baptist say in
Bastiat because that's the way they used
it and indeed the French have suppressed
it that's that that's the scandal but it
originally was gloriously invented by
counting on it 1755 21 years before
Adam Smith published his book and
unfortunately Adam Smith who was
familiar with the French did not use the
word pretty but although he did borrow
some ideas from the French but I wanted
to ask you more generally about your
your idea about the future of
entrepreneurship in in this country do
you think it will be mostly focused on
on information technology or do you see
entrepreneurship happening in other
industries as well oh it can happen
anywhere in old industries as well as
new ones people come up with a bright
idea and get funding for it and suddenly
the world changes the digital revolution
is so extraordinary right now that that
is where the the new niches are opening
that have never been able to be
exploited before and so people are
gravitating towards that meaning you
have you know there are now two hundred
and fifty thousand apps many of them
produced by you know fourteen-year-old
kids that you can get on here I mean I I
couldn't relate but I found out they had
a metronome app I had to download it
there goes tech tech tech tech stuff and
millions of others but there are you
know in any any industry you know as
long as it's still alive that people are
finding new ways to do things because
competition concentrates mines
wonderfully and so if you can find a way
to do something cheaper and better then
you know the Ralph Waldo Emerson said
the world will beat a path to your door
you gotta wait for a mic
hi there thank you I'm an American of
first European descent and we all know
what's happened over the last 2025 years
and the real big question in my big well
disappointment in the whole thing is
what's going on and I just wanted to
know your opinion if you think that
there's a chance that Eastern Europe
specifically Russia who frankly I
consider a bunch of thugs are going to
finally get a European ay-ay-ay
entrepreneurial spirit thank you I can't
think of many countries in the world
less likely to produce an
entrepreneurial spirit than Russia you
know they've had the same I mean it used
to be czars then it was commissar but it
was the same thing of you know a small
group of people at the top deciding
everything and I don't think that's very
much changed in Russia is all hard for
you know great nations to to change
their spots especially if they're as old
as Russia is that's the great thing
about the United States we're still a
very young country and we're we're used
to change we like change we welcome
change we like young whippersnappers
suddenly telling the old folks how they
don't know what the hell they're talking
about in Russia that that's not
culturally approved and so I really
don't see a Russian entrepreneurial
inflorescence anytime soon
a lot of people question whether China
can innovate in the same way as America
has and continues to do
despite their adeptness at copying
American production and building it in
mass quantities they haven't necessarily
had a lot of invention what do you see
about in China's future in terms of the
entrepreneurial spirit
well actually China does have a great
and glorious history of invention
unfortunately what it doesn't seem to do
is then exploit that invention I mean
they invented gunpowder but they only
used it basically for fireworks when
Europeans got a hold of gunpowder we
used it to conquer the world they
invented they had a large iron industry
in the 9th century AD under the Song
Dynasty and it all sort of dissipated
and they had paper money they invented
paper they had in the 14th century and
when the Ming Dynasty was was brand-new
they have great expeditions that reached
as far as the Red Sea and then the Ming
called them back destroyed the ships and
that was the end of the great age of
Chinese exploration followed because you
know China is a very hierarchical
country and the view from the
mountaintop tends to be satisfactory and
so anything that tends to rock the boat
they didn't like very much but they
certainly are inventive and what is
going on in China is is really really
really interesting I be very surprised
if they manage to make a transition to
anything even approaching democracy
without some really ugly incidents in
between I think you know I don't think
you can trust Chinese statistics and you
certainly can't trust the news that's
coming out of China especially outside
of the big cities there's a lot of
unhappiness there I would not be
surprised if China didn't blow up big
time in the not-too-distant future
referring to your closing remarks about
the what you believe to be in the
inevitable failure of Obamacare
I know of no sector of society more
successful in portraying failure as
success than the government I've had a
lot of practice indeed I offer project
headstart which has been an abysmal
failure for 25 your so years and rest my
case on that one what makes you think
that the public will be any less
gullible with respect to Obamacare as
they are to project Head Start well one
thing there are millions of people who
are being directly affected by Obamacare
in the wallet which tends to concentrate
Minds wonderfully and it's just I've
never seen anything like this in all of
American history I cannot imagine a
program a government major program being
rolled out to such a disasterous start
it is really quite extraordinary
I mean I've supposed it comes mostly
from hubris on the part of of Denison's
and the White House who just think
they're the smartest people God ever
made and therefore what they don't have
to listen to anybody but it's really
it's it's it's people that have been
writing books about Obamacare for
decades it's really just terrific they
vote in the House today was they 37
Democrats voted with the Republicans and
that's even after Obama decided to
change the law without bothering
Congress yesterday so I think yeah well
this is we've got miles to go on this
story before it's resolved and I really
be surprised if Obamacare survives and
anything remotely resembling its present
form
sir I wonder if you could revisit
briefly the rockefeller railroad story
I've never spent the time to learn the
real details I've read a little bit
about it but you seem to imply that that
was a rationale for some governments
intervention but it seems to me that
many times early adopters have a
temporary advantage whether it's Sears
Roebuck a and P Microsoft they're seen
as big and evil but eventually that
advantage dissipates and the absence of
government intervention they really
so-called monopolies really can't last
so if if the federal government had done
nothing what might have happened with
the Rockefeller model and I'm not being
rhetorical because I don't I don't
actually know that much but if you could
comment on that I'd be interested in
your thoughts well what happened with
the railroads was railroad economics is
very peculiar economic especially back
then when they had a monopoly on the
long distance transportation of freight
and where the railroads competed well on
the so called trunk lines like between
Chicago and New York where you could
ship your goods on the New York Central
on the Erie on the Pennsylvania they had
to compete in the price they were always
having price wars on the branch lines
where they had a monopoly you know if
you were in Altoona and you wanted to
ship your goods to New York well you had
to ship them on the Pennsylvania or you
didn't ship them and so the railroads
would try to make up on the on the
branch lines what they were losing on
the trunk lines and this they had a
tremendous reputation richly deserved
for being very high-handed
and so there was an enormous groundswell
to get people to get the government to
do something about this the states
couldn't handle it because it was you
know quintessentially interstate
commerce and then they finally
well they did another Sherman Antitrust
Act and then in 1890 of the ICC which
for ten years sat around doing nothing
until Teddy Roosevelt came in what they
should have done I mean what a simple
rule would have solved the problem you
cannot charge a different price on the
branch lines than you charge on the
trunk lines it has to be you know a ton
of bananas can you could charge so much
a mile throughout your system you can't
change that and that you can't charge
this guy more money for the same
business and you charge this guy which
is the rule today I mean um yeah you go
to jail if you try that unfortunately
the government formed the cartel which
suited the railroads
just fine I mean the railroad said if we
can be guaranteed to make 6% on our
investment go ahead and form a cartel
which is what they did and the railroad
industry immediately began to decline
and stayed in continuing decline until
the 1970s now the railroad American
railroad industry is very healthy and
they're making profits and what-have-you
with Standard Oil nothing big the
Standard Oil didn't do anything it was
illegal um what they did do was show
what what laws were needed
um because what was happening in
industrial capitalism was rapidly
evolving at this point and they didn't
have they didn't know what rules
wouldn't were needed the same thing is
you know a beautiful example is American
football which really began around 1869
when Harvard and Yale decided to play
each other but Harvard played a game
that was more like rugby and Yale played
a game that was more like soccer and
they just met on the field in
Springfield Massachusetts which I guess
Yale and Harvard thinks it's halfway
between and they just sort of smooshed
the two games together out of that arose
American football but it took like 30
years to figure out what the rules had
to be I mean for instance in the early
1880s they invented the flying wedge
where the line would fall back into a V
shape walking
arms and the ball-carrier would be
inside the V and they just charged to
the goal line
well this completely ruined the game
because there turned out to be no
defense against it and an awful lot of
people got hurt so within two years the
flying wedge was banned on the other
hand
shortly after 1900 they invented the
forward pass which revolutionized the
game and once they developed rules about
you know who could you know eligible
receivers and know passing in front of
the line of scrimmage and all that sort
of stuff it made a much better game and
now American football they still change
the rules every so often they the other
extra point for you know for you kick
the ball over the goal line rather than
kicking a field goal you get two points
instead of one as a relatively recent
innovation or the in basketball they the
rule that you have to do something with
the ball after what is it twenty seconds
you can't just stand there dribbling
until the clock runs out so this is what
happens in capitalism is that you know
as the game evolves they have to keep
coming up with these new rules and
people like john d rockefeller and
Standard Oil you have a good example of
what rules were needed and and then of
course they in 1911 they broke up
Standard Oil as a monopoly I've always
loved this because they broke it up in
nineteen eleven into I forget 31
different companies by 1913 the the
value of the successor company stock had
doubled so the the effect of breaking up
Standard Oil was to make john d
rockefeller twice as rich as he had been
i'm sure he appreciated that this will
be our final question wait for the wait
for the mike yes can you tell us who the
robber barons were sure the robber
barons were was confusing given by the
the New York Times what a surprise
they use them they didn't they in the
19th 1850s they alluded to the Robin the
robber bounce it's supposed to be these
guys who had castles on the Rhine and
they wouldn't let anybody ship goods
past their castle without paying a
tariff this equipment that in in the
Middle Ages every baron was a thug I
mean they acted like the Mafia and so
the robber barons was just a purely a
term of opprobrium if you didn't approve
of some businessman he became a robber
baron but the term was not fair then it
isn't now I mean Commodore Vanderbilt
was the first person to be referred to
as a as a robber baron and actually a
made a man on Wall Street at that time
Matthew Hale Smith was his name he was
both a lawyer and a Presbyterian
minister which is a rather frightening
combination and he said a Vanderbilt
that the Commodores word is as good as
his bond when it is freely given he is
equally exact in fulfilling his threats
but Commodore Vanderbilt never broke a
law in his life he was a completely
honest man he never took a salary as
president of the New York Central so his
the only way he got so rich was by
enriching you know making the price of
the stock go up and so he made all the
owners of New York central rich in the
process but he was still called a robber
baron it was but it's you know the term
is you know purely opprobrious and
completely inappropriate but I mean I
was as I say it was coined by the New
York Times and it's those kind of people
have been using it ever since thank you
very much
you